steve bannon goes on trial this morning
in washington facing charges of contempt
of congress the high-profile former
chief strategist for former president
trump has claimed executive privilege
protects him from testifying about the
assault on the capitol bit of a curious
claim though because he left his
government position more than three
years before the attack occurred scott
mcfarlane is outside the courthouse
where bannon's trial will be held scott
good morning
hey tony good morning it's jury
selection today for the former white
house strategist and campaign manager
steve bannon accused of snubbing this
january 6 select committee a committee
that's speeding toward its next hearing
and claiming great progress despite
bannon's lack of cooperation
24 hours before the u.s capitol attack
steve bannon issued a warning all hell
is going to break loose tomorrow shortly
after it was formed the house january 6
select committee subpoenaed bannon to
answer questions and provide documents
to reveal what he knew
bannon has refused and will face a jury
this week charged with two counts of
criminal contempt of congress facing a
maximum one year in prison for each
bannon has repeatedly blasted the
committee this is going to be the
misdemeanor from hell until just days
before trial when bannon offered to
finally sit down and speak the committee
says they'd have to negotiate the terms
the panel which has spoken to more than
one thousand total witnesses supports
the prosecution but is still keeping a
door open to bannon is he still of value
to you i would say definitely he is
someone who has much insight
into the call to action for the day of
january 6. he was a mouthpiece
for this stop the steel messaging
and really i think had close contact
with many of the people involved
meanwhile the committee is preparing for
its next public hearing thursday in
prime time focusing on what it calls
dereliction of duty by former president
trump during the riot it'll be led in
part by illinois republican adam
kinzinger who previewed the hearing on
face the nation the president didn't do
very much but gleefully watched
television he said the committee is
still deliberating whether to seek an
interview with the former president i
wouldn't put it past him to even lie
under oath so i'm not sure what the
value is there
trump has called this committee a fraud
and a witch-hunt but it was a judge
appointed by former president trump who
rejected bannon's request to delay this
trial from today until mid-october
meanwhile the january 6 committee says
it expects to get those deleted secret
service text messages the ones from
january 5th and january 6 2021
by the end of the day tomorrow
vlad
all right scott all eyes on thursday in
prime time thank you very much